saying it's one of those things that
makes you think we don't ask enough
questions personally we talk about games
what's going on as a part of the team
but we get to say that
so guys name the team us all of rip
cities sending our love and support to
mr. Allen right now
and that was bitter look at this from
chief who stand led today him get into
my
[Applause]
that defender on his back he's talked
about some of the stuff he's done in the
off season to get his body stronger
understand his body more so did the
Blazers see Jake on the air not going to
get it back from Taj Gibson and save it
to lament
check out and the rotation has been
crisp CJ crossing over to get a three
speeds and economy where that velvety
tuck she's got 13 the get down on the
blood bank
rebound and show you post moves as well
open in the rotation of the defense
drills a three Jake layman and their two
talents asset and sting it off that rim
but he was our just lead here the night
I don't feel right watching this I don't
feel right watching it and enjoying this
[Music]
that is inhumane pass the the screen and
roll reads is one area of where he's
progressed a lot about Rosa Kent getting
a deep this time he throws a cross-court
CJ waiting for him I had to Simon's to
the glass chasing CJ seven to shoot
CJ McCollum spread floor left to right
spin it back step back Park it up man
what a beauty crazy nose after he gives
you the span he's gonna get you with
that jab step and then
[Applause]
[Music]
Leonard solid screen outside man he just
straightened up Trier is this an as it
mate yeah that's it
I think I may have been that made
opening night here's CJ a triple got it
CJ McCollum of the three-pointer the
basket so it's good action to steal
throws CJ outside dancing with a dribble
six minutes gone five takes it inside a
[ __ ] Donna that's a terrific muscular
move as he just backs off Iguodala
literally tacked to the foul watch CJ go
to work here individual one-on-one move
a sir weight room and see he uses that
left arm CJ coming over the top of the
screen meant by Jordan Bell nice diving
Leonard two-hand Jam and the Warriors
need to call timeout Seth looking for
Leonard on the post he's got the six
seven Livingston on gives it to CJ for
this tough shot over Durant
what a beauty that was Oh and that could
have been a tan wonder because the rant
moved underneath them over the top just
picks out the CJ short clock so you got
to do something with it
Paul Millsap being healthy also he got
yogic spying in McCollum a prank away in
a slide
it's 11-hour officials as we've just
settle in here in Dallas throwing it
away is Barnes he was trapped by the
inline right it comes to see Jake come
hospice friend the Turkish for the pop
this team wins at a high level at some
point they'll get that not CJ coming off
the screen screen by Meyers Leonard shot
clock down to two and CJ team enemy knew
CJ coming off the screen
taking temple to the rack lay it up and
lay it in score the bucket brings into
the frontcourt
happy birthday indeed happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you
Danny counts CJ says happy birthday he
blows out Toronto's candle with a
three-point shot Michelle Bingham
operated closely guarded with three to
shoot CJ
drives it between defenders double
clutches banked it in the internal clock
said get it up
he did buy so the Blazers on that 10th
to run CJ get and go laying up two-hand
Jam beautifully done throw it down and
raise the roof now to get some more
basket dribble handoff to CJ goes right
up the gut to the head moving it down
the pike for the two hands
that's how you started overtime and CJ
just kick things off Dante Exum who's
done a nice job off the bench clay
making and playing defenses in deep
three by CJ McCollum a freeze
late in the clock at CJ McCollum
throwing it out to of Gesu for three
needed that one into the fight
it's already quickly doing mean you and
I go outside of CJ is deep three
CJ McCollum finally breaks the spell
they've linked mo use to get the
game-saving steal then let's add a three
Kevin go action CJ converts two-handed
go ahead and rig up CJ's tent dunk of
the year Phil attempt an offensive
rating at once hint
CJ steps back a jumper over Butler hag's
on the air and and it rolls in and that
portends CJ become about a lehigh bit
like it comes to comic - back to CJ cuts
to the hole and packs it with two hands
that filly needs a timeout CJ's racking
up up right here you knocks them down
from the outside you get the nice pass
inside
in the cornet and cornet has it stolen
far away went for the steal and that
leads a mean and wide open to get it to
Macomb in an easy bucket it's a
one-point game
whopper eight Blazers trying it best to
put them away CJ it's kind of the hand
he's got a suit with because he loses
the angle once he's pushed he's heading
behind a backboard they want a few gifts
oh yeah that 2015 nonetheless this is
the 18th ranked and the East is up
tonight let's give a go action in
transition CJ the following god well
that was gorgeous here's CJ coming off
the screen
steps back Ross the defender and knocks
it down Scott Walsh up capped the bucket
CJ watch three eating that's what we're
loving tonight Olympic donald love and
replay got the hot hand he's got
everybody biting at everything
get him up in the air find the body find
the rim
all love in McDonald's 100-point way we
finished that pointcab members on a
regular season date for steep to have to
take threes they didn't want CJ and
Damien if they're making two three four
Hilary they know what those two will do
them CJ and Damien don't get a whole lot
of looks the match flunking me away in
the paint his hand off is knocked down
control finder layman to three-point
range through this these six to go in
the second exuding confidence layman
with fourteen CJ over plays half the
pick
he'll tomahawk one down the Blazers
first that's been CJ holds the fort
he works on Spellman on a switch -
Jacobs bail without good position Dean
but CJ is just a terrific and elite
mid-range and as advisor 6 CJ picking
pot Myers gathers fires the three got
Myers
the letter will he fished the corner
with a perfect shooting mark yes nine
for nine exploded to the rim and then a
turnover by Denver Lily from McCollum
takes it in for the easy
is back to 14 for the blazer and that
hurts whoa were they've been struggling
and a big road trip coming up they go
outside but column putting it down first
quarter in the books from portlet and
after tonight obviously there's the
all-star break then seven games on the
raid McCullum beats the shot clock
buzzer with the jumper that pushes the
lead to five life still Philadelphia
Harris out of a double team loses the
handle CJ races the other way to
security packs with two hands Blazers
have taken advantage who wants it more
right now looks like Portland does
they'll run out CJ's ss15
right being off the screen turns the
corner the galloping dribble kick it
outside CJ and Trump of God oh the good
times are back great setup from Damien
getting all the way into the paint and
suck it into defense get in see Tatum
open 321 it and the Blazers now with a
chance to tie it up this game will be
Sikhs abdali's nice roll
great find inside layman I'm gonna try
that load management from T Oh baby
McCallum it's nothing but net
ten points KJ between Achatz step back
sling at home CJ three and five two
three veterans enter
20 games into the season CJ got it going
13 from the field for threes 24 covered
by Turner out ahead to CJ muscles up
pecs at home and goes to the line man
[Applause]
Randall into the lane man he made
contact with Dirk who goes down on the
floor
CJ the other way to the line landed up
at hand in Dirk is still down on the
other end is on the blazer bench as we
go back to work here plays your
possession up to CJ it'd be nice handoff
to can turn boots back poses back bigs
contact with Smith scores through the
contact Blazers have lost only two times
this season what happened a lead going
into the fourth quarter and they're
getting off to a good start here but
with all due respect to teams like
Phoenix if you see
with the quick handle everything is
looking alright after the score from
Denver the blazes get it out and they go
see Jenelle he's had the bounce in his
step here initially watch him handle
that with nine to shoot and go
one-on-one on Gary Harris terrific
extension that time as he explodes off
the dribble strong she's the jazz on the
glass by the way they were all over the
glass Oh Dave saving a ball and crashing
into season ticket-holder here both
appear to be okay sweeping in is CJ
kappa looked healthy he looked quick and
strong explosive and he looks the same
way on that move never been considered a
good defender those Terry Stotts said
that he feels he's not as bad as people
his fault McCollum status without such a
such a big experience
[Applause]
by that he feels like there's not a guy
on the floor that can got it does not
matter the ability to get to his spot
and make plays time and time again you
gives you a steady diet of scoring in a
variety of ways spectacular offensive
weapon it is down to three Portland a
chance to tie or get within one
here's McCollum this will tire
[Applause]
factory
we're sending too early kitty Charles
and check they got the American Express
halftime report then they go to talk
about with this one he needs some now
like I said their defenses got turned it
off at 4:00 yet individually Paul George
is at the top of that list in both
categories I'm gonna hint from CJ
McCollum
a three-pointer is in Energy Arena in
downtown Oklahoma City Kanter draws a
double here's McCullum now for three
he's some point C in that mismatch
against grant Kanter had 18 in Game one
this Westbrook now lost it on his way up
into the hands in the column pushes it
here's a meal to to triple-doubles in
the flash at 12 during the regular
season but turns it over here numbers
for Portland McCollum
[Applause]
clock at five Murray keeps the ball
steps back double-teamed and turns it
over excellent defensive possession of a
half court at canter is really hurting
Dave but poem pulls up and scores shot
clock down to six McCullum comes and
gets it with a timer for farting on him
McCullum drives two on the shot clock
[Applause]
tell them a little bit of sauce and hits
the mid-range pull-up yeah I see you
yeah I've got another bet
[Music]
CJ McCollum going to work on partner
keeping the Blazers close when we return
[Music]
switches on to Murray
pardon me Millsap the floater in the
paint is going took his time inmate goes
right Yogesh layup blocked by the
rebound CJ McCollum you want to win
show me great recovery and chase-down
block that's a missed layup but that is
absolutely awful defense by the place
the aggressiveness offensively pushing
it with pace CJ McCollum from half-court
getting into the thick of the Warriors
defense getting the basket in the
contact the coach they've got to be
better defensively off of a mate
actually watch you call a couple of old
games yeah that dreams of being the
apartment looks slow to get out hurry on
the drive inside the way Turner picks it
up well it's all alone now green hustles
back what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content